i don't like the word bubble in in the
context of cyber security because
there is actual substance here yeah i
mean
there's there are real technologies
being developed
uh the adversaries are real and
super active i mean every week we hear
about
uh you know new uh a new cyber security
breach
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
i'm sitting today in the yl ventures
offices in tel aviv and i get to talk to
official schreiber about cyber security
the israeli ecosystem and how he's been
perceiving it over the years
meet ofel partner and head of israel
office yl ventures
off schreibel partner and head of israel
office at wild ventures
has broad responsibilities across the
firm's portfolio company management
value-add activities and investment due
diligence prior to joining wild ventures
offer spent three years at ivc research
center researching and analyzing the
technology in venture capital industry
he also served in the elite
technological unit of idf unit 8200
alpha regularly speaks rights and
features and interviews about the state
of the cyber security industry
investment strategies startup
development and israeli cyber security
innovation
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
great to be here thanks for having me
i'm in the yl offices yeah isn't it
beautiful
it is beautiful you walk into the
elevator you immediately encounter an
open space
and with a bunch of light huge windows
facing you which
it was a great entrance you can actually
see the sea from one of the windows here
you have to take a very particular angle
like a lot of places
in tel aviv but yeah in specific times
but uh
but the office has a seafin layer yeah
absolutely we have a
view wild ventures one of the most
noticeable and recognizable funds
in the israeli ecosystem but not just
the israeli ecosystem in the global
ecosystem
but today we're going to talk about
yourself talk about
you know cyber in the israeli domain
here
and and i want to take you back a little
bit law degree
yeah venture capital cyber those three
things
seem very contradictory to each other
yeah i mean i'm a man of contradiction
so
we'll get to that later but uh it wasn't
like that you know back back then
so quick background about about myself
uh i was
in a200 like you right uh but i wasn't
on the technical part of the unit i was
in the intelligence part of the unit
um i studied law in tel aviv university
and
and while i was in university i had a
student student job in a company called
ivc which has the data
it's the database of all the israeli
startups and investors and so on so that
was like my uh
my first peak into the israeli
high tech ecosystem bird's eye peak yeah
exactly and you know very quickly i
realized that
this entire industry and entire world is
much more interesting uh than you know
being a lawyer
uh so i was eager to to
to kind of find myself that the next the
next step in
in the tech industry and specifically in
venture capital
and um you know i had uh basically i had
the database of
all the israeli vcs and for in front of
me so it was relatively
uh uh easy for me just did some research
and you know i
i picked uh really a handful of vc's
that looked
interesting to me and i you know old
school uh
cold emails approached a few wow a few
partners
um and you was one of them you have
lavishdorf who found
the founder and managing partner of wild
ventures and
um there was a great clique and for him
it was a great opportunity as well you
know he
recently founded uh wild ventures he
wasn't living in israel and
investing in israeli startups so he kind
of um looked for somebody to be the
the eyes and ears and israel to have
flow to meet entrepreneurs and so on
so i started my journey in wild ventures
in my last semester in law school
like part-time analysts while at law
school
exactly yeah last semester in in the
university
wow and you know it started as
you know i would say like a short-term
gig
just an entrance to the to the tech
industry
uh but you know obviously you've been
here for nothing
yeah i'm still i'm still learning and
still entering the
world yeah slowly but surely uh but i
kind of grew within within the firm and
took more and more
uh on myself um and in 2013 we raised
our second fund and and i became a
partner
in in the firm and for many years wild
ventures was a relatively small fund you
know you having
in the us me and israel and that was
that was that
um but we grew quite significantly
you're in a nice office uh here in in
rochester boulevard we have an office
just out of uh out of san francisco our
15 people in the firm in total
three partners you have myself and john
brennan who joined us uh
four years ago um we're a pretty big
operation um managing 300 million in
dollars
uh uh over four funds currently
investing out of 135 million dollar fund
so
in a way you can say that my personal
growth story is uh wild ventures growth
story and and you asked me before i mean
it's it's quite unusual that you see a
person who's
working for 12 years in the same place
and you know i have no
no plans of living whatsoever um
but you know from my perspective uh you
know
wild ventures it's kind of like a
startup
yeah within the the vc world right we've
been growing
and changing our strategy for i mean
every few years there's a major change
and we're learning and growing and
becoming
uh better at what we do and bigger
bigger and bigger so in a way
i mean it's very very dynamic and my
role obviously
changed i mean now i'm i'm heading our
israeli
office we're eight people here so a lot
of things to do
from investment marketing team all of
all these different activities that we
do
for ourselves and for portfolio
companies so it's
it's been a an amazing journey you know
for me
personally uh and and for a while
ventures you know
in general it looks amazing now before
before we get to the cyber industry
where we are
as i walk on watching i know that every
other
person that walks in the street is
probably running a cyber security
startup
or when i look or maybe that's just the
bubble that i'm in from from 8200 but
really when i when i
when i look at the bubble that i grew up
in from 8200 it's as if
the world told us this is the this is
this is what you've been destined to do
and it's as if
the whole ecosystem is is here to propel
us forward
and when i think of the ecosystem i also
think that yl's as a huge
terminal where you have vcs that are
very there are very much domain answers
but before we get to that you mentioned
a man of contradictions well what did
you mean by that i'm really curious
um
well you know i think that in a way
if you think about entrepreneurs think
about people in the industry
um i think that the most uh interesting
or most successful
people are ones that have contradicting
features within themselves
i mean i i i pardon me if i don't speak
about myself let's
talk about entrepreneurs because i think
it's an interesting perspective when you
think about what makes
a ceo good or an entrepreneur good uh or
successful
um i think it's it's exactly that it's
the ability to
have um contradicting features and skill
sets
uh between within one person so
just as an example everybody talked
about how
entrepreneurs have to be you know
visionary you know like think long term
see how the world would look like in in
10 years and so on and that's that's
great
but on the other hand um they have to be
like
very very detail-oriented like you have
to know like on on the budget
on cell a35 what's the
exact number and so on if you have only
one of these
qualities you're lacking something
really significant right
another example i think that everybody
says that
an entrepreneur has to be kind of humble
and open to feedback
and you know absorb what you know the
world is saying with customers and
saying
and and so on but on the other hand i
personally
feel that a good ceo has to be a little
bit cocky
as well right you have to have that
confidence because
in essence what you're doing you're
telling the entire world listen
i think i'm i'm developing something
that is not
that's currently not out there in the
world and there is a reason i mean
i identified something that everybody
else missed and i'm right
right and so it's kind of like very
contradicting you have to have
a lot of confidence in what you're doing
and in a way
almost dismiss some of the negative
feedback that you hear but on the other
hand
uh you can't take it too far because i
mean obviously you can learn from
uh feedback and from other people so
these are these are
contradicting uh qualities that
eventually make a good
co or good entrepreneur um and and in
general the thing that uh
interesting people are can be can be
complicated it's not black and white and
and the hard thing in life is to kind of
balance between those things
and understand that you know it's not
it's not black and white right now i i
love the observability about about the
entrepreneur
and the contradictory and i think that
it's not something
i think we tend to be able to do things
in black and white and to take
good extremes so you're good at this
you're good at this
yeah and and that's one of i mean one of
the reasons that
investors like to invest in teams and
not in single entrepreneurs right
because of that because when you look
about all the different qualities that
make
a company successful it's really hard to
find all these things in in one person
so when you look at a
at a founding team um you want to see
different people different personalities
and that in a way balance each other i
think that balance is an important
uh word in our conversation but that's
that's exactly that you need
to find the right balance between
founding teams between founders between
different qualities and skill sets that
they all bring together to to make a
company successful
definitely awesome cyber security yeah
israel yeah settle it for me once and
for all
what has been happening what have you
been observing over the past 12 years
i feel that i feel so lucky to even ask
this question right now because i
grew up you know from the bottom up from
seeing you know how
within the unit and within my friends
and ecosystem things happening but
you're seeing it from above
and so i'm really excited to get into
your brain a little bit so i mean i
think it's it's natural
um i think that for um in in general
the israeli tech industry has been
relying
on the innovation and coming out of the
of the ivf
right as a whole and if you look at you
know
the past generations of of israeli tech
well they're necessarily in cyber
security but they're obviously
you know military and defense companies
that was like
way way back then and in the 90s there
was a big wave of like
telecom and networking and storage and
all these like
massive communication systems but also
that
i mean you can find the trail back to to
everything that has been done in in the
military right
and you know in the beginning of the
2000s that was the rise
of cyber security you know a200 and
other intelligence units
took the shift and became cyber security
units i mean it wasn't necessarily
the case you know back like 20 or 30
years ago those were
you know signal intelligence units uh
relying a lot of
telecommunication and and and networking
technologies and you saw innovation
coming from those areas and now
this is the era of cyber security right
and
these units tend to kind of bring
the best and the best engineers the the
most brilliant talents
uh in tech talents in general and and
these became kind of how i would i would
say the best cyber security schools
uh among the world right so basically
what we're doing
is kind of banking on uh the fact that
we have
the best cybersecurity school in the
world and the best
engineers the best uh technological
talents
going through these uh schools and they
learned you know cutting-edge
technologies they see like
imaginary cybersecurity operations
um and in a very
in a very entrepreneurial um ecosystem
within the military which is also quite
quite unique the way that these units
operate are is
quite different than many other units in
in the idf right of course
and so it's kind of like a uh an
ecosystem that is feeding
itself and you know from our perspective
we identified it
relatively early and what
our story uh in wild ventures the story
of wild ventures growth is
the story of how do we build ourselves
as an organization
in order to um complement the unique
skill sets of
of these young entrepreneurs and
basically enable them to succeed not
just on the technological side but
most importantly on the commercial side
and that's why you know we grew our
our office in the u.s and we've built a
massive network of
of csos and customers and the entire
cybersecurity ecosystem
in the u.s and so we have a strong
presence in israel
strong presence in the us and we kind of
see ourselves as a as a bridge
between israeli cyber security
innovation
and the u.s market so you're touching an
interesting point because until now i
feel like we talked from the inception
to leaving the army it's mind-boggling
to have 19 year olds
after a six-month boot camp come and do
covert operations
that are literally sometimes life and
death and at the end
they leave and they create startups and
then we're jumping to this idea that we
might actually need a bridge because
that might not be enough
for a successful startup maybe it's not
for an operation
so so walk me through what happens to to
these people
these amazing men and women that leave
these units leave these amazing schools
they want to build a venture they have a
conviction that this venture is needed
in the world
they're probably right what what what
are the challenges then
within our ecosystem so i'll i'll add
one more step because it is important
it's an important distinction and this
is a trend that we're seeing in the past
few years in the cyber security industry
in general
i think that the required solutions in
the cyber security industry
is becoming or becoming further away
from
the natural experience of people that
served
in the military okay the skills
that you gain in the military in doing
you know
all this kind of attacking stuff and and
and
learning how like very complicated cyber
operations
work um these are not necessarily
um these are not the main problems of
the cyber security industry these days
on the i mean on the private on the
private sector right
um so you have this um awesome
experience
uh obviously very smart guys or girls um
but they're still lacking uh the
experience and point of view of
what's the what's the difference between
stuff that you did in a200
and how the um and what private
yeah what the private market needs and
how they operate what are their
their challenges i mean just one one
example i mean um
uh cloud security and security
operations and privacy and all these
relatively new things not exactly
the things that that you know military
or cyber security operations have been
engaging with so think that uh one one
of the trends that we're seeing we're
seeing
more and more well the opposite way
less young entrepreneurs in a subsequent
industry i mean
if if like you know five or seven years
ago you had that you know
two guys out of a200 starting a new
company and
they know exactly what to do and so on i
think that's
that's not the case anymore and we see
tr
the trend of these these people getting
out of the military they have a lot of
entrepreneurial passion
but they realize that they need some an
additional step before they
they become entrepreneurs and more more
commonly they start working
probably in their commander's new
startup right
um they gain some experience of like how
actual customers look like what are the
needs and then
and then the next step to
entrepreneurship is
more natural and i guess more
more successful in a way i have so many
questions but i have to run for because
i know we have time soon
the bubble a lot of people exactly
which bubble why do i keep hearing cyber
security bubble and i'm sitting there
and thinking
this is not a bubble this is a market
that is hungry that is forever
that is forever moving catherine now's
game that will never end why is
everybody talking about a bubble
i mean i think that i mean um let's not
be naive i mean obviously
valuations are are extremely high
across all stages from from
seed rounds on the way to ipos and and
so and every everywhere
in between yeah so i mean obviously and
no one will say that it's not true
however i'm i don't like the word bubble
in
in the context of cyber security because
there is
actual substance here yeah i mean
there's there are
real technologies being developed uh the
adversaries
are real and super active i mean
every week we hear about uh you know new
uh
new cyber security breach just you know
a few days ago
the the colonial pipeline and um
uh just every every day you hear about
a major bridge and we're just starting
we're not even seeing
what's actually happening right this is
just the beginning of understanding yeah
and and
you know if you want to understand why
cybersecurity became such a
such a hot topic i think it's not just i
mean there are there are several reasons
for that but
i think that the most important reason
is just the world
it's just a derivative of the pace that
the world is is adopting technology
right the world is becoming more and
more connected going to the cloud
iot all these kind of things
that you know there are a lot of
business values in in adopting these new
technologies but this
interconnectivity um obviously lures
adversaries and and hackers right so
you can't really stop that so that's one
thing the interconnectivity of the world
uh the second is obviously the
explosion of data yeah data is becoming
the
the oil the new oil right and they're
just so
so much more um sensitive data
out there and you add a lot of sensitive
data
with interconnected systems and that's
you know heaven to uh
to uh to hackers and of course on the
other side of the adversary side
and that's not not that's not a new
trend um
you know we see techniques and
technologies and
cyber security operations that until
recently were kind of like
only only nation state actors like you
know
like the nsa y200 had those capabilities
those are basically leaking to um you
know
criminals right you have criminal
operations people that are
are uh financially driven right
have these like massive r d operations
kind of
the same thing that you know uh
militaries
uh had and you know research to find
vulnerabilities
and target targeted attacks you know
similar
similar stuff um financially backed
um so you add all these things together
and
the you know the way that the tech
industry just keeps evolving over time
becoming more and more
dynamic and you just see i mean
i think that chaos is probably a too uh
a harsh word
yeah but there is there is a major major
concern
major concern around cyber security
because you will not stop
the involvement of of technology i mean
organizations
would move to the cloud will become more
connected data
will continue to be generated i mean the
business values
is massive to be stopped so and cyber
security has to be
uh kind of the layer that enables that
if
if we don't protect it we will not be
able to continue
that good trend so this is why
cyber security become such a such an
important
element in in almost everything so
i think that explains you know the rise
of cyber security
you know valuations and and you know the
could the
correlation between uh how a comp cyber
security company is valued
compared to you know its revenues and so
on i mean that that can be
a topic of discussion but but in essence
uh it is real and the substances
is real oh film this was amazing thank
you
so so much for being here i have
absolutely three short questions not
about cyber not about wild but about you
okay i want to go back to middle school
or high school but middle school
okay what fascinated you as a kid what
subject
you're like wow this is my favorite
class or this is my favorite topic
so i really liked uh philosophy uh
yeah i had that like uh even even in
middle school
um and i think that really opened opened
my mind to uh
a different way of thinking like a
higher level of abstraction
uh of the world um and and since then
since then i was attracted to philosophy
and and
even more specifically uh eastern
philosophy like
uh buddhism and zen buddhism which is
like
very very different from everything i
mean
very different way of of thinking and
and analyzing the world or in a way not
analyzing the world because that's the
major difference but it's really really
a
different perspective on on life in
general amazing
and some inspiration a a figure a role
model that
in some way has inspired you across your
journey professionally or personally
so i mean my my main source of
inspirations are my
two children i have two children county
six years old and and dean
three years old and i might not be
original but for me
they are my main source of inspiration i
mean completely
a life-changing experience and and i
think that everything that i do
um both professionally and personally
you know i have them
kind of on my mind and that what
basically
motivates me in life amazing and three
words that you would choose to describe
yourself
okay um i would say
long term but we already talked about
you know 12 years in the same form
looking forward um deterministic
being determined so being determined and
perseverance
i think deterministic is always good no
um yeah we're being determined that's
that's the the term i was looking for
uh in balance uh you know balancing
between between all these
uh different aspects of life um
as we talked about entrepreneurship and
the ability to
ability to balance different things
different qualities
i think it's a super important thing in
life long term determined and balanced
thank you very much it's been a pleasure
you